puis on a appris donc que les russes
avaient coupé livraisons de gaz à deux
pays la pologne et la bulgarie les deux
pays seront approvisionnés par leurs
voisins de l'union européenne c'est ce
qu'a annoncé ursula von der leyen on les
écoute
nous allons faire en sorte que la
décision de gazprom et le moins d'impact
possible sur les consommateurs européens
la pologne et la bulgarie reçoivent
désormais du gaz de leurs voisins
européens
cela montre tout d'abord vivement seul
il a été entre nous mais cela montre
aussi l'efficacité des investissements
passés par exemple en ce qui concerne
les interconnecter heures et autres
infrastructures de galles
voilà la solidarité européenne dit la
présidente de la commission alex le
bourdon vous retrouve à bruxelles
l'europe donc fait face
en effet un autre réponse sera immédiate
unis et coordonnée en voici les mots
choisis par ursula von der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
lors d'une conférence de presse donnée
aujourd'hui ici au siège de la
commission européenne à la suite de
l'annoncé par la russie de l'arrêt de
livraisons de gaz à deux états membres
de l'union européenne la pologne et la
bulgarie ursula von der leyen a aussi
souhaité rassurer ces deux états membres
sur le soutien que l'union européenne
leur apportera elle a notamment souligné
lors de cette courte allocution toutes
les alternatives aux hydrocarbures
russes qui pouvaient exister alors ça on
sait que beaucoup de pistes n'en sont
qu'à leurs balbutiements mais la
présidente de la commission européenne a
tenu à rappeler le récent accord passé
avec les états unis sur des livraisons
de gaz de schiste mais c'était aussi
important politiquement pour orsola von
der leyen d'apporter ce soutien ferme à
ces deux états membres de l'union
européenne surtout à la pologne un vous
le savez avec qui bruxelles est en froid
sur un certain nombre de dossiers comme
l'état de droit mais la pologne qui est
aussi l'un des pays de l'union
européenne qui veut employer le ton le
plus ferme avec la russie merci beaucoup
alix le bourdon pour ces éléments depuis
bruxelles